[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour je viens boire Antoine est-ce
qu'il est là
attendez je crois j'ai une photo
de moi sous la douche pardon c'est pas
la bonne c'est
ça c'est moi ça c'est Mathieu ça c'est
Antoine il y a son ventilateur aussi et
ça c'est Wendo attendez non ça c'est du
café
Antoine il est plus là comment ça il est
pas là il va revenir
[Musique]
du corps qui arrive quand les fonctions
vitales 16 de fonctionner d'abord le
cœur s'arrête puis les muscles durement
enfin il aurait mieux fait de faire des
dégustations des vlogs à la con comme
tout le monde
[Musique]
salut tout le monde dans les années 80
lorsque vous parlez de films d'action la
première image que vous venez à l'esprit
c'était Rambo ça c'est un mec [ __ ] tu
es muscles des explosions des flingues
que demander de plus sérieusement
paradoxalement quand on parle de Rambo
tout le monde se souvient davantage de
l'image du gâteau torse nu avec un
bandana et une mitrailleuse lourde et
qui bute des Vietnamiens de la forêt
alors que pourtant cette image vient de
Rambo 2 et non pas du premier film si
vous avez pas vu le film il s'agit donc
en résumé de l'histoire de mec qui
revient au Vietnam bien après que la
guerre soit finie pour prendre des
photos alors certains de nos hommes dans
le camp qui sera votre objectif vous
devez confirmer leur présence en prenant
des photographies mais vu que les photos
c'est pour les [ __ ]
il y a eu des dizaines de produits
dérivés Rambo des jouets à l'appel des
dessins animés
oui chevauchemissile ça vous pose un
problème et évidemment des jeux vidéo et
étrangement il y en a pas eu tant que ça
en fait 7 jeux vidéo en tout et pour
tout quand tu compares avec la saga
Terminator par exemple qui a eu droit à
une vingtaine de jeux c'est finalement
assez peu en vrai qu'on va trouver
surtout des jeux sur Rambo 2 et 3 vu que
dans le premier film il passe tout son
temps à lui téléphonique on peut
comprendre pourquoi il y a pas eu de
jeux dessus alors pour brasser vite fait
on trouve un Rambo 2 sur Master System
plutôt sympa qui peut se jouer à deux
alors j'ai pas grand chose à dire dessus
si ce n'est qu'il faut impérativement y
jouer à deux sinon c'est beaucoup trop
dur un Rambo 3 également sur Master
System qui se joue avec le flingue
alors j'ai juste un tout petit reproche
à faire
[Musique]
ça marche pas et enfin un Rambo 3
également sur Megadrive qui est une
version améliorée et plus complète du
jeu Master System d'ailleurs au passage
parce que j'ai très envie de vous en
parler il existe aussi un jeu sorti en
2014 sur PC PS3 et Xbox qui est immonde
déjà il s'agit d'un rajouter un rail
shooter en 2014
alors écoutez bien imaginez
Call of Duty en moins beau et en plus
vous contrôlez pas votre perso
tout est raté c'est triste et en même
temps c'est un peu drôle vous savez
quand même bébé pourrait que ce soit les
têtes des mecs qui ont l'air de sortir
d'un jeu Nintendo 64 et [ __ ] ok donc
je sais que dans un jeu comme ça il y a
forcément des textures réutilisées sur
les visages mais je sais pas fait
attention aux gros plan au moins
d'ailleurs en parlant des têtes les
Vietnamiens ils se ressemblent tous
enfin je veux dire ils ont tous la même
tête quoi enfin je veux dire tu peux pas
faire la différence en fait je veux dire
non merde ah oui et au passage si ça ça
veut vietnamien alors moi je suis
Sénégalais bref l'intelligence
artificielle des ennemis est
complètement [ __ ] on dirait d'ailleurs
trilogie sur Playstation 1 quand les
ennemis rentrent devant toi sans aucune
protection mais je crois que c'était
vraiment le mec du son qui était
complètement déchiré sur ce jeu voilà
bonjour
[Musique]
c'est débile alors visiblement après
quelques recherches tous les sons du jeu
sont des extraits du film mais de la
version VHS du film ce qui explique le
son immonde et il faut croire au passage
qu'ils avaient pas les moyens de faire
un doubler ok allez j'accepte l'excuse
concernant doublage mais maintenant
c'est quoi l'excuse concernant le mixage
du son vous savez ce truc qui permet de
pas avoir les effets sonores même niveau
que les dialogues et qui ruinent toutes
les scènes dramatiques
[Musique]
mais celui dont on va parler aujourd'hui
c'est de celui-là Rambo
sur et infâme de la console niveau de
doigt dans le cul on est à 4 doigts et
demi c'est le niveau de dragon SLR sur
NES ce jeu mais
j'en fais encore des cauchemars la nuit
ça va durer des années des années des
années
années monsieur monsieur
et je reconnais vous
êtes youtubeur c'est ça
je vous ai vu dans un vieux magazine
j'ai pas de là
pourquoi vous m'emmerdez j'aurais de moi
vous dire mettez les mains sur le capot
que je les vois
doucement
ouais je m'en doutais vous avez une très
belle main
[Musique]
sinon
vous savez vous allez moi je regarde
YouTube tous les soirs c'est bien mieux
que la télé c'est plus frais pas
l'histoire d'argent pas de course Audi
mat
et pas de placement de produits
dissimulé
c'est bon je peux y aller
utiliser ce feutre blanc ça se verra
mieux
voilà doucement et tout le monde finira
cette journée en vie
bon c'est bon ce coup-ci
ouais c'est bon
[Musique]
une dernière chose vous allez bien en
faire un petit dernier
[Musique]
voiture douce conduite refuse dédicace
sur la Nationale 3 je répète refus de
dédicace sur la Nationale 3 demande de
renfort immédiat
oyez pas les hélico la garde nationale
tout de suite
donc Rambo sur NES je développais par
les mêmes mecs qui ont fait Predator
déjà ça donne la couleur alors le jeu
commence comme pour le film par le
colonel trotman qui vient vous chercher
en prison pour vous proposer d'aller
sauver des prisonniers américains donc
vous pouvez dire non mais c'est comme tu
veux mais le jeu ne pourra commencer que
si tu dis oui
pourquoi vous me demandez alors lorsque
vous acceptez le jeu vous lâche dans la
base déjà torse nu avec seulement un
couteau de merde vous pourrez alors vous
équiper en parlant à un PNJ ce qui vous
permettra d'aller à l'armurerie pour
récupérer votre équipement serait-ce que
fusil pistolet une mitrailleuse non plus
de couteaux
[Musique]
non on commence donc le jeu avec un
couteau de merde et quand je dis couteau
de merde c'est vraiment un couteau de
merde dans ce jeu vous avez trois
boutons un select pour changer d'item
mais pour taper et à pour sauter mais
votre couteau a un défaut majeur lorsque
vous tapez votre animation se fait en
deux frames d'abord Rambo live son
couteau et ensuite il frappe devant lui
alors ça a l'air de rien mais votre xbox
livebox de votre coup ne s'active que à
la frame ou le couteau est devant lui or
regardez la vitesse des ennemis
j'ai même pas eu le temps de lever mon
arme alors bon je sais que dit comme ça
ça a l'air d'être Jupiler de mouche qui
chie dans un bol mais ce micro délai est
horrible parce qu'il vous oblige à
calculer toutes vos actions avec une
demi-seconde avance c'est genre attends
mon couteau s'active 2 secondes et demi
arrive à une vitesse de 3 mètres par
seconde donc si je veux le toucher quand
il est sur moi et merde je devrais pas
avoir affaire des calculs pour frapper
avec mon arme de base alors au cours du
jeu vous débloquerez d'autres armes
comme le couteau de lancer ou l'arc mais
toutes les armes y compris la
mitrailleuse lourde faut moins de dégâts
que votre couteau normal coucou que le
couteau de lancer fasse moins de dégage
dis pas mais la mitrailleuse lourde vous
avez fumé quoi je sais pas enfin je
crois que c'est poils de chat et un peu
de lessive surtout que les autres armes
elles arrivent très tard dans le jeu du
coup en gros plus vous avancez dans le
jeu plus le jeu vous récompense avec des
armes de merde ah bah ça donne envie
d'avance
[Musique]
je peux enfin utiliser la cuillère à
soupe et d'ailleurs pourquoi est-ce que
je dois supplier pour avoir juste un
flingue de base dans un jeu Rambo ta
mère la [ __ ] bon donc le jeu lui-même
est un site scroller action qui est en
soit presque un clone de Zelda 2 comme
pour Zelda vous avez une barre de vie de
l'expérience des potions et certaines
idées sont quasi identiques du genre les
cavernes qui s'illumine que si vous avez
la lampe ou les cartes de marée mais
contrairement à Z la 2 vous aviez une
carte du monde pour vous diriger ici le
système pour s'orienter est une diarrhée
interstellaire sur chaque carte vous
avez ces espèces de carré avec Nord et
Sud marqué dessus et pour changer de
carte vous pouvez où aller jusqu'au bout
de la carte ou vous tenir sur un de ces
carrés et appuyer sur haut pour changer
alors évidemment j'ai pas de problème
avec ce système mais sérieux c'était
trop demandé une simple [ __ ] de carte
et me dites pas de faire la carte
moi-même parce que le jeu ao le sens le
monde il change constamment regardez là
je suis dans un village j'avance je suis
dans la forêt je recule il y a plus de
village que dans la forêt j'avance je
suis dans une plaine là c'est quoi la
gare de Perpignan suite la [ __ ] de
porte de mes chiottes dans mon couloir
va pas m'emmener dans mon jardin si je
la prends dans l'autre sens bordel de
merde et en plus enfile-toi les
changements de map là ou des fois tu
t'es agressé directement en sortant par
un ennemi sans même pouvoir réagir
dans le temps de chargement je me fais
taper dans le temps de chargement de
l'écran ta sœur comme [ __ ] bon donc
alors le but du jeu est de libérer les
prisonniers américains assez rapidement
vous avez rencontré kobao votre contact
comme dans le film à qui vous pouvez
demander une information cruciale ce
qu'elle pense de vous non mais c'est
crucial comme info c'est vachement
important c'est une fille quand même moi
Rambo toi va jouer et donc kobao vous
demandera d'aller faire une mission
annexe libérée un petit garçon dans une
caverne oui kobao malgré ton nom de
déodorant de merde je serai ravi de
pouvoir faire ça si seulement je savais
où il était le jeu il me dit dans une
caverne au nord mais dans ce monde où
les cartes elles changent constamment il
est où le Nord bordel le jeu il mourrait
autant dire le petit garçon il est dans
mon cul ça m'aurait des pareilles et
aussi la ce connard de petit garçon je
dirais bien le sauver toute la [ __ ] de
forêt essayer pas de me faire l'amour
par le cul oui parce que oui évidemment
dans ce jeu on a tout le bestiaire du
petit jeu vidéo pour les nuls les
araignées les serpents les abeilles les
chauves-souris après il y a aussi des
trucs plus locaux hein typique du
Vietnam comme les serpents qui crachent
du feu les
ah non c'est bon ça va
[Musique]
alors comme ça vous connaissez ce type
vous êtes vraiment sûr de pouvoir le
raisonner non c'est vous que je suis
venu raisonné il est surpuissant il
pourrait broyer le crâne de n'importe
qui juste avec ses mains vous carbonisez
avec son regard il est aussi rapide
qu'un train lancé à vive allure il peut
se camoufler dans la foule à l'aide
d'une banale paire de lunettes avec ses
collants bleus et sa cape rouge vous
êtes en train de décrire Superman là le
temps est compté Cherif laissez-moi lui
parler et peut-être que nous pourrons
échapper à son souffle glacial
[Musique]
Père Castor raconte-moi une histoire
qui sont les Snorky tonton Daniel
Mathieu sommaire
ils sont morts que le nez sont tous
morts il reste que moi le monde a changé
YouTube aussi et non tu peux faire de
nouvelles choses tu peux t'adapter tu
peux faire par exemple des prank des
bilogues des challenges les dégustations
on s'est battus pour faire des bonnes
vidéos colonel et voilà comment ils nous
remercient en mangeant du caca c'est
pour ça que je préfère rester dans la
forêt
avec mes amis les animaux
que penseraient les gens de Crypton s'il
te voyait ainsi ouais ça suffit ça
marche pas vous avez essayé maintenant
on va faire ça à ma manière
alors maintenant qu'on a abordé les
défauts on va pouvoir aborder le défaut
et [ __ ] la difficulté de ce jeu n'a
aucun sens même les poissons
parfois
sérieusement je suis perdu j'enchaîne
les Game Over alors que j'ai même pas
rencontré encore le moindre soldat
vietnamienne la nature me déteste
le fun je veux m'amuser pas perdre 79
heures à tourner en rond pour un
objectif secondaire à la con tout ça
pour aller sauver un connard de petit
garçon qui va crever à 14 ans dans une
usine à fabriquer des tennis de merde
désolé oh regardez un flamant rose enfin
un truc inoffensif
ok alors vous savez quoi ce petit garçon
je l'encule
et je retire ce que je viens de dire
c'est impossible désolé elle a caverne
est remplie de ses serpents qui crachent
du feu qui rappelle un peu leur
équivalent dans Zelda 2 mais dans Zelda
2 link il a un bouclier moi tout ce que
j'ai c'est un cancer de l'anus à force
de me faire [ __ ] par toute la faute
locale mais c'est quoi cette gueule de
con là
et au passage est-ce qu'il y a des
Vietnamiens dans votre forêt de
vietnamien non parce que j'aime bien
massacrer la faune locale et tout ça
mais attendez voilà ah
et ils font du kung-fu évidemment comme
tous les chinois du Vietnam ah j'adore
les soldats ennemis dans ce jeu ils ont
des armes qui portent beaucoup plus loin
que la meilleure des vôtres leurs armes
passent à travers les rochers mais les
votre nom ils ont une meilleure allonge
que vous au contact quand vous êtes sur
le rocher vos armes passent en dessous
d'eux mais les leurs vous touche et tous
les trois tableaux vous allez devoir
passer sur ces espèces de pont et chaque
fois que vous faites toucher par un
soldat et demi vous tombez et vous devez
recommencer trois tableaux en arrière et
ça évidemment
beaucoup de vous faites pas tuer par des
bulles oh mais [ __ ] mais la bulle est
sorti en plus là ta mère la bulle [ __ ]
mais mat et moi c'est en faire ça me
toucher ragdal avec une armure de plaque
[ __ ] de [ __ ] de [ __ ] ok alors là
oui effectivement les flashback du
Vietnam c'est justifié
au bout de plusieurs heures de recherche
sur le net même pas dans le jeu faut pas
déconner j'ai fini par trouver une carte
et donc j'ai finalement réussi à trouver
le petit garçon pour ça en fait il
suffisait en réalité tout simplement et
tout bêtement de sauter dans un gouffre
je suis con pourquoi je dis pas pensé
plus tôt et très bien demandant à la
logique des jeux vidéo pour voir ce
qu'elle en pense
[Musique]
et donc le petit garçon avait été
kidnappé par une araignée géante qui
crache du feu
[Musique]
le Vietnam
le Viagra
Vietnam
le Vietnam ça craint bref j'ai buté
l'araignée et sauver le petit garçon
oui je vous ai pas dit mais j'ai aussi
kobao dans mon inventaire donc là en
gros j'ai un petit garçon et une jeune
asiatique dans mon inventaire et j'en
connais un qui va passer des bonnes
vacances
je peux donc enfin commencer la vraie
mission et à les libérer les prisonniers
américains qui ont été enfermés par les
maçons les plus rapides du monde quoi
qu'est-ce que j'étais en train de lui
parler les mecs ils ont reconstruit le
mur derrière moi sérieusement il y a pas
de problème au moins ça c'est facile je
peux gérer allez pas de problème
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais conclure rapidement sur ce jeu
parce que une fois le prisonnier
américain libéré la difficulté augmente
encore une fois le prisonnier libéré
vous vous souvenez de ces trucs qui
permettent de passer d'un écran à
l'autre et bien maintenant certaines
d'entre eux deviennent piégées et te
ramènent en arrière de plusieurs
tableaux évidemment c'est parfaitement
logique c'est sûrement Dieu qui est
arrivé qui a fait aller on mélange la
forêt bref outre ça toute la faune
locale notamment les poissons et les
flamants roses se sont visiblement
métamorphosés en solde la vietnamien et
vous devrez vous enfuir de la base
évidemment en passant par ces petits et
si par miracle tu arrives à passer des
forêts remplies d'ennemis sans aucune
munition ni aucune potion parce que les
ennemis de drop plus rien ensuite le jeu
te fera passer par ici
[Musique]
alors je vais pas vous le cacher on a
pas réussi à finir ce jeu sans tricher
vous savez il existe deux types de jeux
difficiles il y a les jeux durs mais
finissables comme Tortues Ninja et il y
a les jeux stupidement dur et impossible
comme Rambo ou dragon SLR sincèrement je
suis même pas sûr que ça soit finissable
du coup on est obligé d'utiliser un code
de triche pour voir la fin donc voilà en
résumé ce qui se passe dans la suite du
jeu donc d'abord vous retournez sur le
bateau ou votre allié vous a vendu un
vendeur de kebab et à Saddam Hussein
puis ensuite vous faites capturer à ce
moment-là vous allez pouvoir jouer kobao
la vietnamienne pour libérer Rambo alors
dans le film elle se fait passer pour
une prostituée pour entrer dans le camp
mais je suppose que ça allait pas trop
dans un jeunesse du coup dans la version
NES vous vous contentez donc de demander
gentiment la clé de la cellule et tout
va bien tout pour la femme du capitaine
ah ils sont gentils quand même ces
soldats et au passage vous pouvez vous
attacher vous assommer et me donner
votre arme bien sûr tout pour la femme
du capitaine
et là je crois que c'est à peu près à ce
moment là que le mec qui faisait le
scénario du jeu c'est endormi pendant le
film c'est assez pour le noter mais au
début ce jeu suit plutôt bien les scènes
clés du film le bateau la capture de
Rambo libéré par kobao etc mais sur la
fin il y a des tigres en feu des mecs
qui font de la moto d'un CAPR prisonnier
des robots en forme de lune des femmes
enflammées qui lévitent des mecs en
armure du futur des bosses qui ont la
tête qui grossit quand tu les touches
qui est passé c'est dépression il est
développeurs ils ont pété le câble à ce
moment du jeu vous êtes sérieux là ou
foutez de ma gueule ça va on joue
toujours en bon non
David godenas et au passage je confirme
ce que je disais sur la difficulté ce
jeu est impossible à finir je veux dire
sur les dernières heures de jeu le
moindre petit soldat ennemi prend 16
flèches pour mourir 16 vous devez
utiliser toutes vos munitions pour tuer
un mec et le jeu dans mes 12 en face je
peux même plus avancer vous êtes fous
vous êtes des malades mentaux il y a
tellement de sprite à l'écran que ma
console est en train de pisser du vomi
et puis pourquoi vous faites ça le
joueur il en a pas assez chier là c'est
pas suffisant il est diamant et vous
voulez la preuve que les développeurs
ils avaient des chromosomes en trop
quand vous avez fini le jeu quand vous
rentrez à la base vous parlez à un mec
de la base qui vous dit me suis désolé
et là vous lui tirez un Kenji dans la
tête et il se transforme en grenouille
ah oui parce que je voulais pas dit mais
c'est un jeu japonais
écoutez ça fait longtemps qu'on l'avait
pas utilisé dans cette émission alors
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on appelle des gens au
hasard sur leur téléphone et on a un
super invité avec nous c'est Michel
Drucker
te
Michel son con c'est pas la télécommande
[Musique]
j'ai plus aucune douleur oh merci ma vie
peut enfin commencer merci beaucoup
[Musique]
allez mon coco sors de là si tu es
gentil tu t'en sortiras avec trois
dédicaces et un message sur répondeur de
ma petite sœur
allez sors de là tes talents de
camouflage me font pas peur
pourquoi t'insistes pourquoi tu
t'emmerdes tu vois pas que ça sert à
rien que tout le monde s'en fout la
vidéo aurait pu s'arrêter il y a 5
minutes tu as acheté un mannequin pour
faire un plan 10 secondes et tu aurais
fait plus de vues en filmant tes
vacances en Maroc je leur donnerai une
idée à la suivre il marcheront dans mes
pas ils hésiteront parfois ils tomberont
mais le moment venu il me rejoindront et
ensemble nous accomplirons des
merveilles
mais attends c'est pas une réplique de
Superman ça
[Musique]
il était quand même sacrément con
vous êtes obligés de faire ça maintenant